Hello, thank you so much for having me Drew.
I'm so excited to do what we're gonna do today.
I am your humble student,
teach us how to make this beautiful concoction
that you're gonna show us.
Well, I am so excited to walk you through my favorite,
color changing wild violet syrup.
It is so fun and it is so easy.
So first, we have our wild violets
and we are going to take a cup of them.
And the way that we're going to harness
that beautiful shade is by pouring a cup
of hot distilled water on top of our flowers.
In your pot.
Pop, pop, pop, ah.
There we go.
Now, these guys are going to sit in their water overnight
but if you're super cool, like me and Drew.
You're gonna pull little switch-a-rooney.
Wow.
Look at the color of this, it's stunning. It's stunning.
So in order to harness that power,
we are going to take our violet tea.
We're gonna pop it into a pot with some hot water in it.
And we're gonna let that warm up just enough
that this very sweet cup of sugar will dissolve in it.
There we go.
Gonna go ahead and give that pour.
We're giving it a stir.
It's a really good time to do a little,
do a little dance in the kitchen.
Have a little fun.
Oh my gosh, look at your moves, Drew.
You are invited to my kitchen dance parties any all day.
Okay. Now what do I do?
I'm gonna go ahead and pour it into my pitcher.
Okay. I've got a pitcher right here.
In it pops.
So now, we're going to add our lemon juice in
and watch that dark -
(Drew gasp)
Oh my gosh.
It turned pink.
I know.
It's so pretty.
And now exactly, we're gonna go ahead and add in our water.
I have some ice in here too.
In it pops.
And now look at this gorgeous, spring time, pink lemonade
with violets.
It's so beautiful. (humming)
Thank you so much for making this with me today, Drew.
This is a dream.
Oh my gosh.
Tell me how you feel about it.
(audience laughs)
This is how you feel about it. (laughs)
Okay. That is insane.
Right?
That's the best lemonade I've ever had in my life.
Alexis Nikole Nelson.
Thank you so much.
And go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
for the full recipe and Alexis's foraging tips.
Thank you so much
and until we meet again
(upbeat music)